nos dicen que teta está entre p2p y
coseno de teta es igual a menos raíz de
3 sobre 2 y fi es un ángulo agudo
podemos suponer que es un ángulo
positivo agudo o más bien un ángulo
agudo positivo un ángulo agudo positivo
y coseno de fi es igual a 7 sobre 25 nos
piden que encontremos coseno de firmas
theta exactamente sin una calculadora te
invito a que le pongas pausa al vídeo e
intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta
veamos qué podemos hacer al ver que nos
piden coseno de firmas teta es decir nos
están pidiendo el coseno de la suma de
dos ángulos entonces surge la mente la
fórmula que hay para esto sobre todo
porque en este caso nos están dando el
valor de coseno de teta y coseno de fi y
quizá a partir de ahí podemos determinar
seno de teta y seno de fi reescribamos
entonces la fórmula para coseno de la
suma de dos ángulos coseno décimas teta
coseno
y más
z josé noé firmaste está es igual al
producto de los cosenos en este caso
josé 9 fi por coseno beteta es decir
esto es igual a jose no decir que
multiplica a jose no detecta menos y
aquí tenemos un signo más hay que
cambiarlo por un signo menos el producto
de los senos seno de fi por seno de teta
seno de c
por el seno de eta y ya tenemos algunos
datos conocemos que el coche no de fin
es 7 sobre 25 esto es 7 sobre 25 el
coste no de teta es menos la raíz de 3
sobre 2 esto es menos la raíz de 3 sobre
dos y estamos tomando el producto de
estos dos y necesitamos calcular
entonces seno de fi y seno de teta para
nuestra fortuna tenemos la identidad
pitagórica de identidad pitagórica
establece que se no cuado detectan más
coseno quad beteta es igual a 1 lo que
es lo mismo que se no cuado de teta es
igual a 1 - jose no guarde teta
despejamos seno de teta seno de teta es
igual a más menos más menos la raíz
cuadrada de uno menos coseno cuadrado de
teta ya estamos en condiciones de
calcular seno de teta pues conocemos
coseno de teta así seno de teta es igual
a más menos la raíz
de uno menos coseno cuado de teta el
signo menos elevado al cuadro nos da
positivo la raíz cuadrada de tres cuando
le vamos al cuadrado nos queda
simplemente tres dividido sobre dos al
cuadrado así es que es uno menos tres
sobre dos al cuadrado
4 esto es igual entonces a mars menos la
raíz de uno menos tres cuartos lo que es
igual a más menos la raíz de un cuarto
lo que es igual a más menos la raíz de
un medio ahora cuál de los dos va a ser
va a ser un medio positivo o va a ser
menos un medio para ver esto podemos
dibujar un pequeño círculo unitario aquí
aquí tenemos el eje y
aquí tenemos el eje x y aquí está
aquí está nuestro pequeño círculo
unitario y que nos dicen de teta nos
dicen que teta está entre p2p está entre
p2p así es que el rayo terminal del
ángulo teta va a estar en el tercero o
en el cuarto cuadrante nosotros hemos
obtenido que seno de teta puede ser un
medio o menos un medio puede ser un
medio positivo con lo cual teta sería
alguno de estos dos ángulos o puede ser
un medio negativo con lo cual teta sería
entonces algunos de estos ángulos pero
nos dicen que teta se ubica en el
tercero o el cuarto cuadrante y aunque
no sabemos si es este ángulo pues este
otro ángulo lo que sí sabemos es que
para este ángulo teta el seno de teta
tiene que ser negativo así es que para
esta teta seno de teta tiene que ser
menos un medio menos un medio así es que
este de aquí es menos un medio
calculemos ahora seno de fi
seno de fi
es igual a más menos la raíz de uno
menos el coseno cuadrado de fin coseno
de 17 sobre 25 a la eleva del cuadro
tenemos 49 sobre 25 al cuadrado de 625
calculemos esta diferencia 1 menos 49
sobre 625 es 625 sobre 625 menos 49
sobre 625 1 lo puse como esta fracción
para hacer la resta esto es igual a 625
menos 50 es 575 si sumamos 1
esto es 576 sobre 625 esto es igual a
más menos la raíz de 576 sobre 625 la
raíz de 625 es 25 y la raíz de 576
déjame ver 24 por 24 si la raíz de 576
es 24 así es que esto es igual a más
menos 24 sobre 25 veamos cuál de los dos
es el positivo o el negativo checando en
nuestro círculo unitario el seno ya
sabemos que es la coordenada en lledó
secta el rayo terminal con el círculo
unitario y si fuera positivo
correspondería a alguno de estos dos
ángulos correspondería a alguno de estos
dos ángulos pero si el seno fuera
negativo el radio terminal estaría abajo
del eje x ahora nos están diciendo que
fi es un ángulo agudo positivo así es
que estamos en este caso en este caso
con el seno positivo el seno de 111 624
sobre 25 positivo esto es 24 sobre 25 y
ahora tan sólo nos queda hacer estos dos
productos y calcular la diferencia esto
es igual a 7 por menos raíz de 3 es
menos
7 x raíz de 37 por raíz de 3 sobre 25
por 2 es 50 menos pero aquí tenemos otro
menos menos por menos esto es más 24
sobre 25 por un medio simplificamos 24
sobre 12 es 12 esto sería 12 sobre 25 no
de hecho mejor va a poner en 50 vos para
poder hacer luego la suma esto es 24
sobre 50 y ahora si esto lo podemos
escribir como 24 menos 7 raíz de 3 sobre
50 y así hemos concluido